Trascrizione: Arj Hasa
Revisore: Denise RQ
Salve, ho solo quattro minuti quindi
cercherò di raccontarvi
un po' gli ultimi sette anni
in maniera abbastanza stringata.
Voglio partire dandovi una fotografia
della situazione attuale del pianeta.
Al momento,
ci sono cento conflitti in corso,
la maggior parte dei quali
in Asia o in Africa.
Una persona su sette sopravvive
con meno di due dollari al giorno,
e il 10% della biodiversità
che conosciamo oggi
sarà scomparsa nei prossimi vent'anni.
Insomma, non c'e bisogna che vi dica
che la situazione
è anche abbastanza drammatica.
Però voglio darvi anche un altro dato,
che credo abbia il potere
di cambiare radicalmente le cose.
Bene, il 72% della popolazione mondiale
ha meno di 25 anni di età.
Per la prima volta nella storia,
ci troviamo
di fronte una pianeta estremamente giovane
con tanto potenziale spesso inesplorato
e soprattutto grosse opportunità
che fino ad oggi non era possibile,
ad esempio le nuove tecnologie.
Su questi due assunti fondamentali
anche dei strumenti basici,
si base il lavoro punto
di Interaction for Change or IAC
un'organizzazione globale
Interamente gestita da giovani
che offre ai giovani stessi la possibilità
di diventare protagonisti attivi
del cambiamento in positivo
nelle proprie comunità.
Come lo fa, in maniera semplice;
offrendo corsi online gratuiti
metodologia peer-to-peer.
Quindi giovani che insegnano
ad altri giovani le basi dei diritti umani
dello sviluppo sostenibile,
del project management
oppure del fundraising,
della raccolta di fondi.
Tutto questo contando che appunto IAC
è oggi presente
in centotrenta paesi del mondo,
e insegna a migliaia di giovani ogni anno,
partendo con centocinquanta euro,
una cifra che insomma
forse fa anche un po' sorridere
perché centocinquanta euro è
poco più di un pezzo di un paio di scarpe.
Mi trovo
una conferenza proprio come questa,
quando ho avuto la mia idea.
E ho pensato appunto di tornare in Italia,
proporla un pò in giro
sono passata da enti da istituzioni,
dall' università.
Ma mi si diceva sempre
un po' la stessa cosa:
"Tu quanti anni hai?"
All'epoca ne avevo ventidue,
quindi mi rispondevano
"Guarda, se avesse magari
trent'anni di più
non avrei problemi finanziarti,
a ventidue proprio non me la sento."
Diversamente, mi dicevano:
"Bella questa idea, assomiglia a..."
ma in realtà niente, siamo i primi
a fare una cosa
dal genere a livello globale
ah quindi non siete la brutta coppia
di un'organizzazione americana
o qualcosa di simile.
Per il momento no, eh allora dato
che siamo in Italia
mi parlate di fantascienza.
Dopo sei mesi di porte chiuse in faccia,
ho deciso di lanciare una organizzazione
quindi una novazione
che dal Italia arriva al resto del mondo
e che da appunto i giovani l'opportunità
di cambiare in maniera radicale
le cose dalla Colombia all'Uganda,
dal Butan al Malawi.
Se c'è una cosa che posso raccontarvi
che ho imparato,
mi manca pochissimo tempo,
è proprio il fatto che ognuno di noi
ha nel proprio piccolo,
l'opportunità di cambiare le cose
e che non bisogna essere straordinari
per fare cose straordinarie
quindi insomma, assolutamente,
ognuno di noi ha veramente il potere
di attivarsi in prima persona
e di cambiare quello che non va
e questo è un po il lavoro
che fa IAC
in maniera molto semplice
e molto diretta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)